Nicholas is in Korea hi Nicholas our you
good morning Dave good morning how are
you
it's just doing well doing well better
than I deserved
what are you doing in Korea serving I'm
an Army soldier sir now thank you for
your service sir
it's an honor to serve how can I help
they absolutely I find myself facing the
decision where I kind of feel like those
old cartoon characters or you got the
devil on one shoulder and the angel on
the edit no problem is I don't know only
problem is I don't know which one has
the halo which one have the horns gotcha
I figure I call you to get a third
opinion okay I'm about two months I'll
be returning home mm-hmm and I sold my
car before I before I came so and then
been kind of living a Spartan istic
lifestyle has managed to save up about
$20,000 while I'm here should be about
22 to 23 by the time I at home my
question is is should I go back to kind
of what I was what I was doing when I
get home and buy like a roll to $3,000
beater or should I buy the car that I
really will really want which is an old
Porsche how much is it right around that
23 mark okay I spend all the money you
have no money that's outside of an
emergency fund outside of a dump run sir
I mean maybe I should mention I'm also
on step 6
oh okay all right so you have an
emergency fund and yeah and and so on
okay and what is your household income
about 135 K okay I buy the Porsche I was
not expecting you to say that okay it
sounds a small it's a small percentage
of your income it's above your emergency
fund and and it's a dream car for you
warning you're going to write some
checks keep that puppy running on I'm
already I already got that as a budget
item sir okay because you know what
that's you know what that's kind of what
your model are you talking about I was
looking at a 996 so it'd be right around
the 2003 mark okay all right yeah I mean
that's just a high maintenance vehicle
there wonderful car I mean they drive
down they drive like a
beast but you're going to write some
checks keep that puppy running and keep
it on the road it goes with the
territory you make 120 though you've
saved the 23 it's a small fruit you know
as long as the total of your how of your
cars and things with motors in them is
less than 1/4 of your take-home pay are
I'm sorry less than half your take-home
pay which it is then you're in good
shape and you've got the cash hey you
save the money it's what you want to do
it's why you work you know if you told
me you're using your emergency fund or
going to use your last dollar to do it I
wouldn't do it oh that would just make
me twitch sir I wouldn't be able to do
that good well you have a good twitch
then it's not a man again thank you for
your service and enjoy the car hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]